with the weather looking to be wonderful
this weekend most likely you're planning
something outdoors and if you're
thinking about heading to mount
charleston area
you might want to start early as people
will be there to camp
picnic hike just check out lee canyon
summer experiences
victoria saha shows us all the
activities being offered
carving out some family fun time this
weekend drive an hour outside of las
vegas and you're in lee canyon
you know we got great activities for
everyone obviously just you know hiking
along the bristlecone trail is
is always fun lee canyon officially
kicks off its summer season
definitely with you know the pandemic
people were you know
cooped up and you know outdoors was
definitely an outlet the outdoor
industry association reports
last year more than 8 million people
went hiking
and enjoyed experiences outdoors so lee
canyon is ready to welcome those people
back
offering scenic chair rides horseshoe
throwing disc golf
and new this year axe throwing
there are even instructors on hand to
teach you how it's done
and given how busy it's expected to be
you're asked
to be respectful and don't leave any
trash behind
we're promoters of outdoor recreation
and we also promote the
leave no trace lifestyle so you know
pack it in pack it out
victoria saha 8 news now
lee canyon is open friday through sunday
the summer season will run
until labor day